[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis marine j'aime l'odeur de
l'herbe coupée du chaume et celle de la
forêt jamais entendre le bruit de la
pluie qui tombe sur la toile de tente
la neige glacée qui craquent sous les
bottes et le feu qui crépite dans le
poêle je déteste les bruits de
mastication humide et l'amertume du
pamplemousse je suis marine et ce soir
j'ai envie de m'adresser à vos sens
je voudrais vous parler d'alban alban à
deux ans et demi c'est le fils d'une de
mes amies et l'automne dernier je me
suis retrouvé dans la rue avec lui et on
devait aller rejoindre sa maman sur un
chemin qui si on avait marché
directement nous aurait pris peut-être
15 minutes mais là alban il marché et il
écouter le bruit de ses pas sur
l'asphalté après des câlins peut il
continuer à marcher parce que sur le
bord y avait des cailloux et encore il
écoutait le bruit de ses pas dans les
cailloux et un peu plus loin il a touché
les feuilles qui déborde de là et il a
levé la tête il a regardé les oiseaux
passent et les nuages ce chemin c'est
devenu un voyage ça nous a pris genre 40
minutes et souvent on dit que les
enfants sont perchés mais moi je trouve
qu'au contraire sont vraiment bien
ancrés bien là parce que leur rapport au
monde spontanément ils et sensorielle et
nous aussi en tant qu'adulte notre
rapport au monde reste sensorielle même
si on oublie souvent et moi ce soir j'ai
envie de vous inviter à un voyage un
voyage sensoriel
vous aurez pas besoin de vous lever de
votre banc ni de derrière votre écran
c'est un voyage que vous allez faire à
bord d'un vaisseau qui est aussi banal
qu'extraordinaire ce vaisseau là vous le
connaissez bien vous l'habiter chaque
jour c'est votre corps alors c'est parti
pour un voyage enfin qu'est ce call
la première escale c'est le sens du
toucher
on peut toucher grâce aux plus grands
organes sensoriels qu'on possède c'est
la peau on a deux mètres carré de peau
en moyenne de mètres carrés parsemez de
plein de capteurs qui vont nous
permettre de percevoir les pressions les
caresses les températures et notre
sensibilité n'est pas la même sur tout
notre peau
alors je vous présente le manque ulus
c'est une représentation du corps humain
où chaque partie du corps a une taille
proportionnelle à sa sensibilité donc
vous voyez bien qu'il a des immenses
main une immense boucher une immense
langue salée partie du corps on est les
plus sensibles et on comprend bien en
voyant ça pourquoi pas spontanément on
va associer le sens du toucher à la main
et pourquoi les enfants ont tendance à
attraper tout ce qui traîne et à les
mettre à la bouche en fait c'est une
manière d'explorer le monde qui est très
précise
le sens du toucher
comme tous les autres sens il est
essentiel à notre survie par exemple il
va nous indiquer la douleur il va nous
indiquer des potentiels brûlures et nous
permettre d'agir pour ne pas abîmer
notre corps c'est lui aussi qui fait qu'
on sait où est ce que notre corps
s'arrête et où le monde extérieur
commence
quand on rencontre quelqu'un pour la
première fois on se sert aussi du sens
du toucher dans beaucoup d'endroits de
la planète pour créer un lien humain en
europe en amérique du nord en amérique
du sud on va se faire la bise se serrer
dans les bras ou se serrer la main mais
il ya d'autres endroits du monde comme
par exemple à bornéo aux philippines ou
encore chez les inuits ou quand deux
personnes se rencontrent elles vont
s'approcher d'une de l'autre très
proches de manière à pouvoir sentir
l'odeur de l'autre et c'est comme ça
qu'il se saluent
le sens de l'odorat c'est notre deuxième
escale c'est mon sens préférées sûrement
parce que je suis très sensible aux
odeurs et aussi parce que c'est le sens
qui est le plus relié aux émotions et à
notre identité
on sait que le nez humain peut percevoir
plus de 1000 yards odeurs grâce à une
toute petite zone qui fait la taille
d'un timbre et qui se situe à peu près
ici et pour l'explorer je vous propose
une petite expérience olfactive alors on
a plusieurs d'entre vous avez vu vous
avez des vaporisateurs devant vous donc
c'est le moment de s'en servir donc en
faisant attention à ne pas en mettre
dans les yeux de vos voisins et vos
voisines je vous propose de vaporiser
autour de vous et vous pouvez tous
agiter les bras pour que ça se répandent
et je vous demande
l'odeur que vous allez sentir
comment est-ce que vous l'aimez
et s est au delà elle vous le rappelle
quelque chose
on va essayer de faire ça 1 le plus dans
le calme qu'on peut pour que chacun ait
envie d'une expérience la plus agréable
en tout cas j'en entend des rires ça a
l'air plutôt agréable
alors on va faire un petit sondage à
main levée qui est ce qui n'a pas du
tout aimé cette odeur
kiev qui a aimé un peu cette odeur
et qui est-ce qui a beaucoup aimé cette
odeur alors là ce soir on est majorité
de personnes qui ont beaucoup aimé
l'odeur est ce que cette odeur vous a
fait penser à quelque chose un lieu une
personne un endroit où vous êtes déjà
allé moi c'est une odeur quand je la
fait sentir souvent quand je donne des
ateliers on m'a déjà dit ça me rappelle
les crêpes de mon enfance ça me rappelle
un voyage en tunisie et les pâtisseries
orientales ça me rappelle ma nourrice
que j'allais quand j'étais enfant et se
parfumer avec cette odeur et moi
personnellement ça me rappelle la
brioche alors en fonction de notre vécu
des histoires des odeurs qu'on a quoi
raconte croisé dans notre vie on va pas
avoir la même appréciation ni la même
évocation il ya peut-être même des
personnes pour qui cette odeur n'évoque
rien du tout et c'est en ça que le sens
de l'odorat est très relié à notre
histoire se faire sentir une odeur à
quelqu'un c'est ouvrir la porte à
échanger sur l'histoire de chaque
personne
pour les personnes qui ont eu un
souvenir qui a surgi vous venez
d'expérimenter ce qu'on appelle le
pouvoir évocateur des odeurs c'est
quelque chose qui a été rendue très
célèbre par marcel proust avec la
fameuse madeleine trempé dans l'infusion
de ti elle qui l'a ramené à un souvenir
de son enfance qu'il avait de dizaines
et de dizaines d'années en arrière alors
pourquoi t'as fait ça en fait quand on
vit une émotion forte qu'elle soit
joyeux ou tristes le corps va imprimer
en mémoire l'ensemble des sensations du
moment et quand en plus tard des
semaines des années des décennies après
on recroise une de ses sensations et ben
ça réveille le souvenir ça peut être une
chanson ça peut être un lieu ça peut
être un paysage mais les odeurs ce sont
elles qui vont faire ce rappel le plus
rapidement possible et je pense que ça
fait aussi partie des choses pour
lesquelles je trouve que ce sens est
vraiment fatiguant
je vous demande maintenant de réfléchir
enfin de penser à votre auteur préféré
et maintenant l'odeur que vous détestez
le plus
j'ai pas mal prêt à parier que dans les
odeurs que vous aimez il ya des odeurs
de fleurs d'aliments de plats de forêt
peut-être de personne que vous aimez et
dans les odeurs que vous détestez d
odeur de putréfaction de poubelles de
moisi
en fait le sens de l'odorat il participe
énormément à notre survie du point de
vue alimentaire on va être attiré par
les odeurs de choses qui sont bonnes
pour nous qui sont comestibles et on va
être complètement révulsé par des odeurs
de choses qui sont toxiques pour nous
on s'en va vers notre troisième escale
celle du sens de la vue le sens de la
vue il est quand même très pratique pour
se repérer pour trouver le bon chemin
pour éviter les obstacles et on s'en
rend d'autant plus content quand il ya
du brouillard et moi il ya quelques
semaines j'étais à dijon et à dijon de
temps en temps je sais pas si vous êtes
déjà allé il ya du brouillard et ça
bouge pas pendant plusieurs jours et la
dernière fois que j étais c'est ce qui
s'est passé alors on a pris une voiture
on est sortis de dijon a à peine 20
minutes c'était grand ciel bleu grand
soleil on est allé dans une forêt sa
santé le sous-bois unique de l'hiver
l'air était vraiment frais et agréable
et je marchais sur le chemin et
j'écoutais le bruit de mes pas et puis
j'ai vu ça
et j'ai pris une photo je sais pas si
vous voyez quelque chose mais moi j'ai
vu un visage de femme je vois souvent
des visages ça peut être dans mes
tartines de matin quand j'ai plus des
légumes quand je regarde les bouches
d'aération sur les toits des maisons ce
phénomène s'appelle l'appareil dolly
c'est le fait de détecter un visage
humain ou une forme animale dans un
nuage une tâche d'encre les traces d'eau
sur le trottoir par exemple c'est un
phénomène qui contribue à notre survie
lorsque sa découlerait d'une
hypersensibilité à détecter les
présences et ça c'est quand même
pratique si la présence en question et
menaçante ça nous permet de réagir et
peut-être de partir en courant de se
mettre à lutter sauf que c'est un
phénomène qui est très sensible mais par
contre ça manque de précision donc
parfois il ya des ratés on voit des
présences là où en fait on n'a pas
en parlant de reconnaître les choses
est-ce que
vous reconnaissez cet objet
cet objet ça s'appelle un masseur de
tête caresse de luxe quand j'étais un
habitat grillon parce que j'étais à
gryon ya plus de 15 ans j'en avais un
dans ma chambre et chaque fois que mes
amis venez en général c'était la
première chose qu'il faisait et le
prenais il le mettait sur eure sur arte
est et donc les personnes qui ont réagi
j'imagine que vous savez que ça crée en
quelques centièmes de seconde une
sensation de frissonnement de picotement
qui envahit tout le crâne qui descend
dans le coup on est proche de l'extase
et cette sensation alain allemand elle
s'appelle la smr peut-être que vous avez
déjà entendu ce nom là parce qu'il a été
popularisée au début des années 2010 par
des vidéos qui porte ce nom et qu'on
trouve vraiment beaucoup sur internet où
on voit des personnes qui manipulent des
des produits cosmétiques des aliments
qui vont les manger et qui
s'enregistrent avec des capteurs très
très sensible il parle aussi avec une
voix chuchotée et apparemment chez
certaines personnes
cessons la provoc la smr moi
personnellement ces vidéos là elle me
fascine parce que c'est pas du tout des
sons qu'on a l'habitude d'entendre cd
sont vraiment de l'ordre de l'intimé
mais à la fois ça me dégoûte parce que
je suis mise au fon clin d'oeil à ma
soeur et mon beau-frère son pareil la
mise aux faux ni c'est une aversion pour
certains ce qui ne dépend pas du tout de
l'intensité parce que parfois il ya des
sons très forts qui vont être
désagréable lassé des sons qui sont très
légers et peut-être que si vous êtes
déjà retrouvé dans une file d'attenté
derrière quelqu'un qui dégoûte hissait
qui mâcher un chewing gum qui se racler
la gorge ou qui reniflait et que vous
trouvez ça insupportable a peut-être que
vous aussi vous êtes misophonie
le bruit des chips ça fait pas du tout
partie des bruits que je déteste au
contraire quand j'entends quelqu'un qui
froisse un paquet de chips qui loue et
qui se met à en manger mais a tout de
suite j'ai envie d'en manger aussi je
sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
eh bien il ya des chercheurs et des
chercheuses dont le sujet de recherche
et l'impact des sons sur nos préférences
à nos comportements alimentaires
et il ya un chercheur qui s'appelle
charles spencer qui a démontré notamment
que quand on mange des chips en ayant
sur les oreilles un casque dans lequel
est diffusé le bruit de quelqu'un qui
mange des chips mais les chips qu'on
mange elles ont l'air encore plus
consciente
je sais pas si ça vous donne faim mais
on est rendu à notre cinquième escale le
sens du goût le sens de la gustation qui
nous permet de percevoir les saveurs
et je vais vous raconter une anecdote il
ya à peine quelques jours j'étais avec
un ami et son fils luo wen qui a 9 ans
et on avait acheté deux cafés et un
chocolat chaud à emporter on est allé se
poser au bord du canal de l'ourcq et la
loi n'a attrapé son gobelet il a bu une
gorgée et là il a fait une grimace
l'avait arc mais le café c'est vraiment
pas bon habite il a cherché le gobelet
du chocolat chaud il a bu une gorgée
c'était bien sucré et là son visage
s'est détendu et tout allait bien je
raconte cette anecdote parce que en fait
on est programmé à la naissance pour
adorer le sucré est également le gras
est détesté la version et il ya un
chercheur dans les années 80 qui a
démontré que cette préférence est cette
aversion était innée et universel chez
tous les enfants de la planète et ça
s'explique par le fait que le premier
aliment qu'un enfant doit manger pour
grandir c'est le lait maternel qui est
un aliment qui est gras et sucrés et
donc les enfants qui se sont bien
alimenté parce qu'ils étaient portés
vers cet aliment ils ont grandi ils se
sont reproduits ils ont transféré cette
préférence à leur descendance
et la version pour l'amertume par le
fait qu'il ya beaucoup de plantes
toxiques qui sont amers et donc ça
protégerait le petit humain de
l'intoxication alimentaire
sauf que il ya aussi beaucoup d'aliments
comestibles qui sont amers et c'est là
que les enfants ont besoin des adultes
au même si qu'ils ont besoin des adultes
de leurs parents et des adultes
référents pour apprendre à parler
apprendre à marcher ils ont besoin de
nous pour apprendre à aimer une
diversité de goûts et donc cette
éducation au goût elle se fait avant
tout à la maison mais elle peut se faire
aussi par exemple à l'école ou en camps
de vacances
on vient d'explorer nos cinq sens par ce
voyage de survol sens le sens du toucher
sans le sens de l'ouïe sens le sens de
l'odorat sens le sens de la vue et sans
le sens du goût et bien notre vie
justement n'aurait pas le même goût
on a parlé de beaucoup d'organes
sensorielle et il y en a un que je
voudrais rajouter maintenant qui est
essentiel c'est le cerveau parce que
c'est lui qui fabrique notre
représentation du monde à partir des
sons des lumières et des matières que
sont les saveurs les textures et les
odeurs du monde les informations
sensorielles sont envoyés par voies
nerveuses sous forme de signaux
électriques hélas le cerveau fait la
synthèse entre les informations
sensorielles la mémoire les émotions et
la paf sacrés comme une carte postale
sensorielle et émotionnelle de l'instant
présent et même si a priori on habite
tous le même monde mais notre perception
à chacun elle est unique
parce que oui on a tous des organes
sensoriels on est semblable mais par
notre génétique on ne va pas avoir la
même sensibilité et à ça s'ajoute notre
culture notre éducation nos habitudes de
vie notre âge et peut-être parfois aussi
les maladies et les accidents qui
peuvent nous arriver certaines personnes
sont plus sensibles que d'autres par
exemple tout à l'heure l'odeur que je
vous ai fait sentir l'odeur de fleur
d'oranger
certaines personnes ont peut-être trouvé
qu'elle était très forte d'autres
moyennement et d'autres peut-être n'ont
rien senti et pourtant c'était la même
odeur et vous avez tous et toutes
raisons parce que oui chacun ses goûts
mais aussi chacun sa sensibilité
alors nous sommes des êtres semblables
mais aussi des êtres uniques et même si
en grandissant en devenant adulte notre
pensée notre rationalité prend de plus
en plus de place pour guider comment
nous vivons et comment nous habitons le
monde on reste des êtres sensorielle et
émotionnelle
nos cinq sens sont notre seule interface
avec le monde
je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
mais quand on mange un aliment ou un
plat et qu'on se dit ah mais il ya un
goût mais j'arrive pas à mettre le doigt
dessus et lors d'un voisin qui dit assez
chouette ils ont mis du cumin c'est
vraiment super bon et là d'un coup la
sensation de cumin à la part est énorme
et on la sent hyper forte c'est un peu
comme si
le langage venait jouer un rôle de zoom
d'augmentation de sensations alors moi
je me dis si les mots peuvent nous
permettre de vivre le monde plus
intensément peut-être avec plus de
précision mais pourquoi ne pas essayer
d'enrichir notre vocabulaire sensorielle
et si on prenait aussi le temps parfois
juste pour quelques instants de porter
attention à nos sensations quand on
mange quand on rencontre quelqu'un quand
on se promène dehors quand on est assis
ici en train d'écouter une conférence
il ya quelques jours je m'en allais à
pied animé un atelier du goût un atelier
où je fais découvrir par la dégustation
avec des cinq sens toute une variété
d'aliments et j'avais mon cabas dans
lequel j'avais tout mon matériel et mes
aliments et je marchais vite et j'étais
pressé et je pensais à tout ce qu'il
fallait pas que j'oublie et tout ce que
je voulais leur dire et je me suis
retrouvé derrière une personne qui
marchait avec une canne
je voulais pas doubler parce qu'il y
avait des voitures sur la route la
personne devant moi je voulais pas la
bousculer alors j'ai ralenti
j'ai levé la tête et j'ai vu des
magnifiques sculptures qui avait sur les
bâtiments j'ai vu le ciel bleu j'ai
senti
l'odeur de la boulangerie à côté de
laquelle je passais j'ai entendu le
bruit de n'est pas sur l'asphalté et
puis j'ai pensé à alban et j'ai souri
je suis marine
j'aime l'odeur de l'herbe coupée du show
mouillé et celle de la forêt j'aime
observer la diversité de vos visages
j'ai aimé entendre vos exclamations au
silence et vos respiration j'aime sentir
vos odeurs qui se sont mélangées à
celles de cet amphithéâtre et à celle de
la fleur d'oranger pour créer l'odeur
unique de cette soirée
alors ici avec vous je savoure
l'ensemble des sensations de cet instant
présent qui se termine maintenant
[Applaudissements]